- You either dwell on it
for the rest of your life
and decide the reason you
weren't successful in life
is because when you were 19, your brother
stole $8,000 from you,
or you put that chip on your shoulder,
and you get more motivated
than ever, and you go harder.
(peaceful piano music)
Every minute's accounted
for, so when I'm on,
I'm on.
It's 15 hours, tight, all
in, morning to night, period.
What I know is I know that
how the platforms work.
When you have a direct ask at the end,
when it's about go fill
this out, go donate,
you've taken 50% of the energy
out of the piece of content.
When there's an ask in the same time
that there is a setup, you've lost equity.
- So the strategies--
- The charming guy at the bar,
who is a very nice, one-hour conversation,
if his last thing out of his mouth's like,
"Alright, you want to come upstairs?"
He kind of defeated a lot of the setup,
whereas if you just--
- Never thought about it that way before.
- But this is how I think about it, right?
But like, this is a very
good way to think about it,
'cause it's very universal and
every human understands it.
Had that been turned into another date,
and another date, the mission could
have been accomplished for whatever
the agenda was at hand.
That's where I want you to go.
Because, you have to understand why.
Every person that reads and consumes that,
I can cookie and re-target them,
and ask them separately in
a different environment.
It's not like a gala.
- It's relationships.
- In a gala, when we're
at our highest emotion,
yes, that, you know, in the moment.
Not digitally.
- Yeah.
- Got it?
Digitally I got that.
It's like if I went to the gala
at the highest emotion, but you put
a little bug on me and you could
talk to me all the time.
You see?
It's a different setup.
Guys, thank you so much.
We'll be in touch, yeah.
I think for all of you the truth
is always the answer.
I think you should test an education,
and a, like, you're teaching and
you're keeping up with them,
but you're doing it tactically.
I'm not talking about
a mastermind, you know?
I'm not talking about like, details.
Like, the way this is forming,
like, you're getting into real details.
Like it's just details.
So I think if you're able to continue
to educate people on details, like
why did Snap-, Snapchat changed last week.
So now there's new details.
I'm playing with it, every day.
And my whole thesis that I told everybody
for the last two years,
like don't give up,
last year, don't give up on Snapchat
because if they make a move,
my Snapchat consumption's up 100%.
Because they changed the UI,
and they're favoring personalities now.
Anyway, like that.
Like, LinkedIn made a change,
Facebook had its change,
Instagram's organic reach dropped,
like in the world we plan,
there is a need for constant weekly
updated with everything.
And like it took him and everybody else
like whoa, this guy plays it different,
masel tov, but then you,
the reason I do that is I don't
want to give ammo to anybody.
Drake, the commercial with his liquor,
where his dad punks
him, is why Drake wins.
Drake's smart.
Drake really understands the game.
Drake knows that he's gonna be
hated on for his style of
actor, pretty boy, singer, rapper,
so he, he, I think
Drake, more than anybody,
uses the "8 Mile" thesis of he's gonna
make fun of himself.
You know why Drake can't lose a battle?
'Cause he's gonna shit on himself,
there's nothing Meek or
anybody else can say.
He's gonna say it.
So you can't say, "You
can't rap, you sing."
It's already over.
Honestly, here's what's up.
Like, I want to start a show called "And."
I've been thinking about
this, I'm gonna call it "And."
People are gonna call in,
tell me their problem,
and I'm gonna say, "And?"
Right?
It's a good show, right?
Like, tell me anything.
My, both my parents were crackheads.
And?
Like, uh, I lost my job.
My husband's beating me.
And?
Look, these are real shit,
I'm not fucking saying
these are small things,
these are the hardest things in life.
Here's my question:
life's about alternatives.
What the fuck are you gonna do about it?
Leave your husband.
I get it, you live in a house that's nice,
and you don't know how to
work, and you've never worked.
But you want to get punched in the face?
Absolutely not, that's
fucking unacceptable.
And.
- [Premium Pete] I love it.
I can't wait for it, I can't wait for it.
I need to come on there and talk to some--
- But think about it, right?
Pete, like, what what--
- [Premium Pete] No, you're right.
- I'm gonna call, brrrrrrring,
make sure you, make pretend
you have the "And" show.
Ready?
Pete listen, but you don't understand,
like, my my brother, my older brother, he
I had $8,000, I've been
working three jobs,
and he walked in my room
and stole it, and left.
- [Premium Pete] And?
- That's it.
- [Premium Pete] Or I can
say what the fuck, and?
- No, no, no.
Just and, and.
- [Premium Pete] Okay, my bad.
- And.
And you either dwell on it for
the rest of your life, and decide
the reason you weren't successful in life
is because when you were 19,
your brother stole $8,000 from you,
or you put that chip on your shoulder,
and you get more motivated than ever,
and you go harder.
- [Premium Pete] Well, people deal with
a lot of depression these days.
- No shit.
You know why?
- [Premium Pete] You ever get depressed?
- I don't.
- [Premium Pete] How the fuck?
Yo, you're not normal, bro.
- I'm not normal, bro.
- I'm not fucking normal.
- [Premium Pete] You never get depressed?
- I get disappointed and frustrated,
but actually thinking, like I'm
always macro-optimistic, like I got life.
The fuck do I have to be, I'm in control.
I think people are depressed when
they don't have things into context.
They don't realize how lucky they have it.
And two, they don't feel in control.
It's tough, I don't get
depressed, I get, I get,
I get critical on my actions.
I get thoughtful.
When I'm in a bad place I'm like,
okay, what am I doing that's wrong?
Like, but listen, my chemic-, listen
this is an illness, some people
have chemicals that, like this is about
my brain is right.
Like I have to be thankful for that.
But here's my thing, I don't know how
to teach, how to get
people out of depression,
I'm just trying to change
people's perspective.
It's awfully hard to give
when you have nothing to give.
It's awfully hard to--
- You can't give what you don't have.
- I've come to realize, wow, that's right,
I realized I was so talented,
everything's a foregone conclusion,
that I'm able to give more than I take,
because I don't need
anything from anybody,
I can get it myself.
When you're self-fulfilling,
you become super dangerous,
in the slang term of, like,
you've got all the leverage.
- You do see it as ledger, right?
- I do, 100%.
And I think the key with me,
when I say I'm more of it
than anybody I've ever met,
I mean what I'm about to tell you.
Nobody has ever disappointed
me in my entire life.
- That's awesome.
- It's a really important, like, concept
that I don't speak to a lot.
Nobody has ever let me down.
Nobody has ever let me down because--
- Is that self-actualizing
or is it more forgiveness?
- No, it's actually neither.
It's, it's I have zero
expectation of others.
- Really?
- Mmhmm.
And that's, I think, what I'm realizing
is the purest form of
giving without expectation.
Like, I don't, I don't give more to you
than I give to your daughter,
because you have more to give to me back.
It's just that I look at you two the same.
It's a very weird game, man.
Like, I equally think that Zucks
can do as much for me as Schmucks,
because I don't know how it all plays out.
- Right.
- But way more importantly,
it's not even that strategic.
I'm not looking for the other part.
- Yeah, I--
- I mean, this is real, and--
- You're detached, you're detached.
- I'm detached, bro.
Like, when we, when we meet, right?
- Yeah.
- You meet me at an interesting point,
when we meet, which is I have a new baby
called VaynerSports and you have a lot
of leverage to give to me,
even in that moment, I can't get excited
about the thought of like, quid pro quo,
or like, I'm gonna give to him
because in two years, he'll give,
like, it just doesn't run through my mind.
I don't want to meet anybody,
like I'm about to meet the amazing
all-time Warren Moon,
I'm gonna say one thing,
which is the '91 playoff
game against the Jets
really pissed me off, Warren,
and I don't want to be your friend.
Like, it's not gonna be, it's not--
- I'm glad I'm not a football player.
- It's not, it's a very weird game.
It's, it's a strength and a weakness.
It's why I also don't have mentors,
and I've left a lot of
opportunity on the table.
So when I'm on, I'm on.
It's 15 hours, tight, all-in,
morning to night, period, right?
But when I'm off, or
when I'm at a Jets game,
or when it's vacation time, I'm off.
And I can shut it off and on,
and I'm winning in those extremes.
And I believe there's more of that allowed
than people think, because I think people
are being half-pregnant on both.
Like they want a work/life balance,
and they're working nine to
five, they're coming home.
Or they think like, I don't know,
I just think people have it confused.
I think there's more
victories in the extremes,
and that's how you balance out.
It's like a bridge.
A bridge is fucking extreme.
You gotta cross from
one side to the other,
there's a big fucking ocean in the middle,
and they're pulling hard as fuck
from those two opposite sides,
that's how I think of myself
and I'm trying to teach that a little bit.
Babin, remember the new rule of three
Snapchat pieces of content?
Oh, you weren't in the meeting?
- [Babin] I wasn't here Friday.
- You were bouncing around when
we had our biggest meeting ever.
- [Babin] Exactly.
- Guys, I'm supposed to be doing way more
Snapchat content, but Babin wasn't there
for our big meeting last Friday
because he was just bullshitting,
so sorry 'bout that.
It's my fault ultimately, but
let's also tweet out "Boo Babin."
Hit me up on Twitter and go "Boo Babin."
Like it's one thing, if, like,
you know how we got into this cadence,
he wanted to show something
on his big computer, right?
But I'm always, I feel like, with no joke,
I'm obviously making jokes,
it's more about them
getting their full meeting.
If I'm left to me getting down there,
they're in deep shit, and we always lose.
Whereas if they're here, I feel like
they're losing 10 minutes every meeting.
You know what I mean?
Now, on the flip side,
I should probably go down there,
'cause it's like the few times
I actually get downstairs,
so there's also that.
So it's a real tough decision, Alex.
You make the call.
(laughter and excited yelling)
You have to pull from opposite directions.
Yes.
- Super quick question, alright.
So your gold play button is ready.
- My what?
- Your gold play button,
like that other one.
- Oh, I have a gold play button now?
- Yeah, 'cause you hit a million.
- I love how I don't even know
what YouTube's, okay, and?
Like people's entire
lives are about getting--
- Put a gun to your head,
you wouldn't have know what
a gold play button was.
- If you didn't point to that,
I had no shot, okay?
- Yeah, um, you want it to say
Gary Vaynerchuk, like that?
Or do you want it to say Gary Vee?
- What do you think?
- Well, uh, so I'm in the middle.
I, I think that it's just up to you,
because D-rock says Gary
Vee matches sale branding,
Andy says Gary Vaynerchuk matches
your other play button.
I say Vaynerchuk.
- I think--
- He's going against D-rock.
- I want, no, D-rock wants Gar--, I want,
D-rock, you're gonna love this,
we're going with Gary Vee.
I feel like I have a Gary Vaynerchuk,
so let's go with Gary Vee.
I was actually smiling, because
basically my schtick is to razz with you,
and I'm, like, happy for you
that you won this round.
Congrats, D-rock.
- Sounds good, thank you.
- By the way, by the way.
Actually, this just happened,
we are not doing enough
of the human stuff in the vlog.
Like this stuff happens every day,
and it's not in the vlog,
'cause we're staying very
prescriptive to bring value.
I think breaking up, you know,
or maybe I'm also not watching that much,
so this is a little bit of my perception,
but, what's that?
- Same page.
- Em, you and I are
always on the same page.
- I know.
It's really refreshing.
- Babin, that's exactly when you
should be filming something for Snapchat,
but once again, even though I've--
- [Babin] I don't know what the rule is.
- You're a big boy.
You should have been able to,
like the fact that you weren't
able to pick up on the nuances
of what the rule was.
I know you know what the rule was.
I said to you, you're supposed--
- [Babin] I know, you
make Snapchat comments.
- What fucking rule?
Like what was confusing?
Hey bro, I even said the number,
I said, hey, we're supposed to make three
Snap-, I literally verbatim said to you.
Can you please recall it
for the vlog right now?
Babin, remember the new rule of three
Snapchat pieces of content?
Oh, you weren't in the meeting.
And then I even made a snap about it.
Boo Babin.
And now, I just brought it up again.
That's exactly when you should be
filming something for Snapchat.
And you claim that you
don't know what's going on.
Kids, excuses are always the wrong answer.
(hip hop music)